hello everyone i'm back after a hiatus
of several weeks
for doing our annual summer school and
high school summer camp
which uh both of which went really well
and uh
produced i don't know 120 130
original research projects between them
lots of interesting work lots of um
things that i've been wondering about
for a while that finally got done
so that's exciting but now i'm back and
um
i'm going to go on with these live
streams um
we're maybe refactoring these a little
bit and be interesting people's input
i'm thinking of doing a few more
interview style
live streams
and um i've done several in the past
um
they um
uh be interested in people's suggestions
about uh
people that i should interview
anyway let's get back to what we're
doing here today which is a q a about
history of science and technology
and i see a question here from zaiden
how was it determined that light travels
at a constant speed in a vacuum
i think i know the answer to this the um
so
uh
the question
uh
it was
the
one question is what is light
and there have been a wave theory of
light and a corpuscular planet particle
theory of light
going back
well certainly into the 1600s and
possibly even much earlier than that
and there have been effects like newton
certainly knew about kind of wave
related phenomena um like newton's rings
and an oil slick things like this
um and yet there were other places where
it seemed like light was more uh
of of particles corpuscles and so on so
it was not completely clear what the
nature of light
as
a
as a thing was
um
the thing that
i think really began to converge on that
was
i mean that there were effects in light
that seemed sort of wave-like
diffraction interference these kinds of
things there were other effects that
seemed kind of particle-like i think uh
thomas young of young slits and so on uh
in the 1800s um
was one of the uh
proponents i think of a wave theory of
light but it kind of went back and forth
a whole bunch
um
now people have measured the speed of
light
uh from looking at
things like the transit of the moons of
jupiter
and later i think fit so i think it was
measured
um
the uh even in the 1600s i think had
managed to measure with sort of a
toothed wheel
spinning fast had made it managed to
measure the speed of light
um on on earth terrestrially and um it
was certainly known that the speed of
light
you know sort of getting to jupiter was
comparable the speed of light on earth
things like that approximate values to
the speed of light would know and those
kinds of things um
what i think wasn't very clear
was the following question
if you have
a sound
if you have sound
and you emit sound
sound is vibrations in air the air is
stationary and if you are a fast moving
thing
the sound you emit
can't go
any faster than the speed of sound
relative to the stationary air even if
thing the thing you're emitting it from
is uh is going quickly and it's it's um
so that leads to
uh
uh leads leads to all kinds of effects
but
the um you would uh
um
you would expect
that
the
speed of the thing that you emit
is somehow relative to the speed that
you're going at
rather than being and if you're going
fast you would expect that that sort of
uh this is confusing um
uh the that um well so so the the sort
of the question of
is
when you emit light from something or
emit sound from something is the speed
that things go at
relative to
the speed that the thing that the thing
that was emitting it was going at or is
it some kind of thing relative to some
sort of absolute
uh
uh ambient
uh
carrier of the waves
okay
so then
we come to the eighteen
70s around that time
and james clerk maxwell who is trying to
really organize what's known about
electricity and magnetism
and trying to make systematic equations
that describe
electric fields and magnetic fields
and what he ended up with is four
equations
that um uh uh use what we now call
vector calculus
uh things like the divergence to the
electric field this proportional to the
electric charge
the curl
maxwell considered calling curl twirl
but he didn't
curl
of uh the
magnetic field is proportional to
electric current things like this these
are the equations for electric fields
and magnetic fields the idea of of
electric fields and magnetic fields had
really been pioneered by faraday
earlier in the 1800s
and had noted things like you know when
you see the iron filings arranging
themselves around the magnet you can
think of this sort of the there being
lines of flux that go through the um uh
the the iron filings and define the um
the the sort of define this thing that
faraday who wasn't terribly
mathematically oriented abstractly
thought of as a as a vector field
um then
what happened was there was sort of the
combination
of of applying
um calculus to vector fields and so on
and to fields in general and that led to
things like vector calculus and made it
possible to formulate maxwell's
equations as this collection of four
partial differential equations
okay so then
uh given those four partial differential
equations well one of the notable things
is
they allow one to have wave solutions
they allow and have solutions just like
the equations for
uh compression in air the equations for
motion of of fluids like water and so on
they allow wave-like solutions so
similarly the equations of
electromagnetism allowed uh wave-like
solutions
and uh heinrich hertz notably realized
well that means you should be able to
transmit signals just through
electromagnetic waves and he set up
experiments where he had a spark gap
that was was producing a spark that made
electromagnetic waves and they could
pick up the effect of that
somewhere else the the voltage induced
by that somewhere else and that was the
first example of radio and famously when
people asked him what's this good for he
said oh it's just an interesting physics
experiment it won't be good for anything
um and of course radio did turn out to
be good for lots of things and and
people like marconi and so on uh fairly
quickly picked it up as a an ultimately
very commercial kind of concept
but um
i think the uh
one feature
of um
uh the of of maxwell's equations
and this idea of of uh propagation of
electromagnetic waves there was sort of
the question what are the
electromagnetic waves propagating in
because what people had seen before
was always
these examples where waves were waves on
water waves and sound waves and air
compression waves and air and so on and
they expected that there was some
carrier
of whatever would be wave-like motion
and so there came people started talking
about the luminiferous ether the light
carrying ether
and and some kind of uh of background
thing that would exist in the universe
just like air
allows one to have sound waves the
luminiferous ether would fill the
universe and allow one to support uh
light waves
and in the eighteen hundreds that was
kind of what people assumed would be
going on
but one of the predictions of the
aluminum first ether
was that there was should be an ether
drift it should be the case that when
you are moving
uh that there should be a a rest frame
there should be a
you know just like with air the air is
at rest and you can move through the air
and so on but there is an overall kind
of rest frame for the air and so people
assumed that the same must be true of
the luminiferous ether
and so then there was an experiment done
in 1900 by michaelson morley to detect
the ether drift to basically detect the
effect of
uh this stationarity of the ether on the
propagation of electromagnetic waves or
in particular light waves
and so what they did was to look at the
sort of uh as the earth goes around in
its orbit how would that affect uh in
different positions in the orbit you
would expect different effects of of
different
uh motion relative to this luminesce
first ether was there such difference in
in
in the propagation of light
answer well no
um it didn't it seemed to go
at um in particular at the same speed
independent of the direction that um uh
the earth was uh independent of where
the earth was in its orbit in what
direction it was going because the earth
is going in a circle so it's gonna it's
gonna cycle through different possible
directions relative to this luminous
luminiferous ether
so
uh that was sort of a big uh big kind of
thing how could it be the case that
there was no etherdrift if there was a
luminiferous ether
um
and
but nevertheless
in
um
let's see in maxwell's equations
the
the speed of light
is
a constant in maxwell's equations
and so this was all very confusing and
the big sort of uh
breakthrough was 1905 when einstein
uh realized that you could kind of make
the sort of constancy of the speed of
light in maxwell's equations the absence
of ether drift
of consistent by assuming that
space and time
uh were themselves not
um were somehow not absolute kinds of
things
so in particular
that so so a typical sort of thought
experiment is you've got this flashlight
it's producing light the light's going
at speed of light you run with the
flashlight does the light that comes out
of the flashlight go at speed of light
plus the speed you're running at or does
it just go at the speed of light and you
can make it consistent to think it just
goes at the speed of light by changing
the way that you measure uh distance and
and time
um according to the formulas of
relativity you can think about this in
different ways and we do in our physics
project
in terms of sort of breaking things up
into these very granular kind of events
of this happens now this affects
something else and you build up this
kind of causal graph of events but
that's perhaps a more complicated way to
think about it the thing that was sort
of the realization
from from um
uh
einstein was that by changing the way
one thinks about space and time one can
make it consistent to have the speed of
light be constant
independent of how fast you're going and
so on
so so from that that seemed to be kind
of um
the uh
theoretical sort of explanation of the
constancy speed of light
in terms of measurements of the
constancy of the speed of light um i
don't know all of the all of the data on
that
um
and in fact i think there are um
let me see uh how would you measure that
um
well let me say the following that
uh this whole idea of the luminiferous
ether and the fact that
one of the things that sort of came out
in relativity theory was the idea that
there is no sort of preferred rest frame
there's no sort of frame in which uh the
the ether is at rest and uh things are
moving relative to that instead
according to relativity one should think
of things just as relative to the
observer and all that matters is the is
the relative velocity of things relative
to the observer not the absolute
velocity of the observer relative to
some kind of global uh sense of of zero
velocity in the universe
well so
so went the sort of the the rhetoric of
relativity from 1905 on
but in fact
it's not really the case that there's no
preferred rest frame in the universe
because the universe has has stuff in it
it has matter in it
and that matter is the universe is
expanding but there is
a
a a frame in which there is a uh the
when when the universe started out there
is a the matter was sort of sitting
there and it's gradually expanding but
it's still the case that the the uh sort
of the overall structure of the universe
defines a preferred frame in the
universe how do we see that
well if we look out in any direction in
the universe we eventually see back to
light that started its journey towards
us
soon after the very beginning of the
universe soon after the big bang 100 000
years after the big bang or so and that
we see that light in all directions in
the universe
but
we that that light is was emitted in a
sense from from the the hot scuff that
was in the big bang and there was a
definite rest frame for that stuff
and so in every direction in the
universe light is coming to us at about
2.7 kelvins um or
electromagnetic radiation is coming at
about 2.7 kelvins and it's all it all
has
it's all
uh how the the um
the the frequency of that light the
distribution of frequencies is the same
it started off being the same in all
directions but when we observe it it's
not the same in all directions why is
that it's because we are actually seeing
a doppler shift we're seeing the effect
of the fact that we're moving in a
definite direction relative to this rest
frame of the universe defined by the
original matter the material that was
that existed in the big bang
so in fact
it it is the case that we're moving at
about a thousandth of the speed of light
relative to the rest frame of the
universe
so this idea that there is no
sort of fixed ether
that
is um
is sort of a a defines a rest frame for
the universe it's not really true there
is a fixed definition of the rest frame
of the universe
defined by the original structure of the
big bang
now
it is also true
that if we ignored that if we just said
we're in a very closed box that doesn't
have any effect from any of that relic
radiation or any of those kinds of
things then
the claims of relativity should be true
and there really wouldn't be any way to
know what the what the sort of preferred
rest frame was
well of course there's another little
footnote to that
which is in quantum field theory there
are continual vacuum fluctuations
and
there's also a preferred rest frame for
those which is defined uh in a slightly
uh by again by this sort of rest frame
of the universe
and it gets even more complicated when
you start talking about quantum gravity
when you look at our models of physics
it actually gets somewhat simpler again
and once again there is a
in some sense a preferred rest frame for
the universe
um
and uh although it
it because of causal invariance
which is eventually leads to things like
relativity
you can't it does not have an effect on
measuring many kinds of measurements
that you might make that there is such a
preferred frame so anyway long
long-winded answer to this question
about um
the constancy of the speed of light i
think um
the uh
uh
it is the case
that
uh the
the idea that it's truly
independent of the speed of the emitter
and other kinds of things
is something that is to an incredibly
high degree of approximation true
and
is theoretically true in a true vacuum
but there isn't actually a true vacuum
in the universe there are quantum
fluctuations
everywhere
in unless you're in a sort of a box that
excludes it you have the cosmic micro
red background and those things will
define a precip preferred rest frame and
will induce a tiny change
in
the uh effective speed of light
um by the way
things get even more complicated when
you start thinking about the speed of
light in the very early universe and for
example in our models of the early
universe
we think that the effective dimension of
the universe was much larger than three
and that kind of one way of
parameterizing that is to imagine that
we have much larger or possibly infinite
speed of light in the very early
universe so so it can be a complicated
thing what the effective speed of light
is and by the way even in our current
universe
our models expect that there may be
dimension fluctuations and those again
have a bizarre effect on on the notion
of what the speed of light is
um
let's see so that was a long answer to
that let's see there's a question here
from matt
about the history of the hard sphere
model and statistical mechanics
okay so
essentially the
um
the hard sphere gas is sort of an
idealization of an actual gas with
molecules bouncing around and so on
well people had talked about the
possibility of atoms
as discrete elements of the world back
in antiquity
but they weren't thinking about kind of
the mathematics of things bouncing off
each other and so on
i don't think that
in the time of newton and so on when the
laws of mechanics were first being
discussed i don't think there was a big
intersection
with a corpuscular theory of matter at
that time in other words i don't think
people that really thought about the
idea that matter might be made of atoms
and how would the laws of mechanics
apply to those atoms
that really uh there was a lot of
confusion about
uh what heat is heat eventually is the
motion of atoms but people not knowing
about atoms didn't know that that was
what heat was in the early 1800s there
were things like phlogiston which was
this kind of fluid that represented the
presence of heat
rather than heat being this
characteristic of atoms
by i think 1830s were things like brown
in motion
and also uh people like dalton
had studied chemistry
and had given sort of uh arguments for
why it seemed like they were discrete
atoms in the world and and between
actually observing sort of kicks on a
pollen grain in brownian motion and this
idea that chemistry worked out very
nicely if you had integer numbers of
atoms for things this started to emerge
in in the
by the mid 1800s i guess the idea that
yes mata might be made of atomic
components
well then
people like um
uh
boltzmann
um
let's see were there precursors to that
um
well boltzmann proposed
certainly talked about the idea that
atoms were bouncing around and this
notion that atoms that heat was a form
of motion i think that had arisen
slightly earlier than that that heat um
oh my gosh maybe people like clausius
had talked about heat as a form of
motion
the idea that heat was not this fluid
but instead was the representation of
the motion of of atoms
so so boltzmann kind of actually wrote
down equations that represented things
like collisions of atoms and things like
this
meanwhile maxwell
in um
i think there was a a prize being given
for an analysis of the rings of saturn
and maxwell entered that prize
and i'm not sure he won but anyway i
think maybe he came second but um uh he
as part of sort of studying what the
rings of saturn might be in little
little particle-like things although big
bigger like grains of stuff
studied this question about collisions
between things and the effect of
collisions
and uh
derived the maxwell boltzmann
distribution as it's called which gives
the the typical velocity of particles
that are colliding with each other so in
typically the the um it's
e to the minus velocity squared um well
v squared times that is the is the
probability that you get a molecule of a
given velocity in a gas and that's
derivable by knowing that these
molecules are bouncing off each other
and colliding and it's derivable as kind
of a an aggregate fact
um you can derive it by just using sort
of probabilistic arguments thinking
about every collision and thinking about
how energies and momentum work in each
collision
well
the maxwell certainly i think 1860s
maybe 1870s was very interested in this
whole question about how
things molecules might bounce around and
run into each other what kinds of
distributions of velocities you get and
so on and i remember years ago i was
looking at um some stuff he'd written
about it and he considered all kinds of
different shapes of molecules like a
molecule that's in the shape of a wedge
a molecule that's in the shape of a cube
and so on how would they bounce off each
other um and uh but sort of the simplest
case is
spheres bouncing off each other
okay so then
the um uh
that was but but so
what had been derived at that time was
maxwell the maxwell-boltzmann
distribution a thing called boltzmann's
equation which has to do with
representing kind of the probability to
find a molecule with a particular
momentum and so on and how that evolves
but these are all sort of probabilistic
arguments that don't involve the
specific looking at uh spheres bouncing
off each other
so then uh well time goes forward a bit
and i think the next things that start
getting talked about
are
uh really sort of mechanics questions uh
related to things like billiards you
know you've got these billables they're
bouncing off each other what happens
when they bounce off each other uh
people like poincare considered that
around 1900
and in particular notice that if you
repeatedly bounce these balls off each
other every time they hit each other if
they hit a little bit more off center
the amount off center that they hit will
progressively amplify a sensitive
dependence on the initial conditions the
sense of dependence on exactly where the
first hit of the billiard balls is
so
the thing that was a big obsession in
the early 1900s was to understand how
one would go from both sort of how gases
worked
and how one would get things like the
royal venture be increased working how
one would get sort of the aggregate
behavior of gas molecules how that all
worked
and the thing that was introduced was
the so-called agonic hypothesis
which basically said that when molecules
bounce around they're random enough
and they're bouncing around in any
particular case they're bouncing around
that you can assume that they've bounced
around in a way that corresponds to the
probabilities you would get if you
looked at all possible ways of bouncing
around not just the specific way of
bouncing around that happens in a
particular kind of uh instance a
particular threat of time so that was
the ergotic hypothesis people very keen
to to prove or disprove the ergotic
hypothesis for different kinds of
systems one of those systems was the
hard sphere gas system i think a person
called krylov did a bunch of work
in the 19
maybe 30s
people like the aaron fests were another
other people who worked on these kinds
of things there were a bunch of people
working on kind of foundations of
statistical mechanics in the 1920s 1930s
who were interested in things that
amounted to
kind of billiard balls bouncing off each
other
and and a number of results were derived
about sort of how random the
distribution of of of billiard balls
would be
after some number of collisions in a in
a container in a sort of on a billiard
table of different shapes and and so on
so that was that was kind of um i think
the things that happened from a
theoretical point of view was the study
of the ergotic hypothesis
and the importance of uh and how sort of
hard sphere gases would um
would behave in that way
um
well then
in um
uh
well people used kind of um
uh
people used
kind of things like uh ball bearings as
kind of analog models of lots of kinds
of things like people are interested in
in liquids for instance
and people then thought about well if
you just got a bunch of sort of ball
bearings and smooshed them together what
configuration would you get or more to
the point if you got a bunch of of uh
non-rigid ball bearings and smoosh them
together what configuration would you
get how would that correspond to for
example the configuration of biological
cells and tissue how would that
correspond to the position of molecules
and liquid these kinds of things that
was stuff that was of interest in around
1960 or so
quite a lot people like um
bernal
and uh
a bunch of people um studied those kinds
of things
so those were sort of analog examples of
hard sphere
quotes gases but the hard sphere system
then computers came into the picture and
um
there started to be computer simulations
of of hard sphere gases or something
like it
and um
a
person called bernie alder a person
called wainwright these were people who
um in the 1950s i think were starting to
do computer simulations of hard sphere
gases in the hope that you would see
phenomena that will like what you see in
real gases kind of an analog of that was
done by
enrico fermi uh john pastor and stan
ulam
at los alamos in the mid 1950s
there with a very early computer they
did an experiment on a collection of
objects with springs uh separating them
and they said what would happen if you
just start these objects you just wiggle
the springs around and you let these
objects wiggle around kind of randomly
what would happen if the springs are
ordinary linear springs you get very
simple behavior but if you have
non-linearity in the springs what would
happen they saw that as another analog
model
for what happens in in things like
gases and other systems that occur in
statistical mechanics
what they observed was the surprise that
even though you might think that there
would be that things would sort of go to
equilibrium quickly and that there'd be
sort of random motions of all these
weights on the springs what they
observed was some sort of long-time
coherent structures that could emerge it
later became clear that those are
solitons uh which have been actually
studied in in fluid mechanics
um a hundred years earlier actually um
but uh hadn't really been concentrated
on and it was only only later than that
in the 1960s that people really
understood this notion of integral
systems
and uh these kind of special solutions
to certain classes of partial
differential equations but any case the
um uh the thing that um
that happened in um so firmly pastel
ulam was an example of a computer
experiment a very a rare and notable
example of a computer experiment that
was intended to explore statistical
mechanics that was done in the 1950s uh
older and wainwright um
then did similar experiments on hard
sphere gases
the um the foaming pastel line
experiment was done at los alamos
national lab um the uh
all the wainwright stuff was done
in a lawrence livermore lab um in
california um and um
they
used a um that they first did those
experiments i think in the late 1950s
um they were starting to try and see
what would happen with a hard sphere gas
for example if you s
if you the spheres are bouncing around
they're they're they're behaving like a
gas but let's say you make the density
of the spheres higher or you squash the
volume down lower would there eventually
be a phase transition and would you see
something like a liquid or a solid
clearly if you if you squash the spheres
enough you'll see a solid because the
spheres are packed in uh densely but uh
you know what kind of intermediate
behavior would you see
and they used a computer i think it was
called the lark
they used a computer uh to
uh try and um figure this out and they
at that time the display was like an
oscilloscope and so they could see
little dots on the oscilloscope screen
that represented the motion of these
particles bouncing around
now actually in my own uh little
intersection of my own history here
uh
the
one of the places where the sort of
the in the end hand redrawn
frames that came from this uh photo
photography of the oscilloscope screen
um
there were sort of these these pictures
sort of the a movie strip representing
the the sort of motion of molecule of
these uh of hard spheres and so on
and um uh that was sort of a good
example potentially of statistical
mechanics and of things like the law of
entropy increase the tendency of these
spheres to get sort of more and more
randomly distributed around the box and
so on
well that example wound up on the cover
of a book uh it's part of the berkeley
physics series
i think it's
volume five of that about statistical
physics statistical mechanics
that was a sort of standard
undergraduate physics textbook series
produced in the 1960s
um
okay ma what's my intersection with this
well
the statistical physics book had this
nice green book it has this this cover
that has a sort of film strip that shows
this um kind of behavior of the of
supposed behavior of a hard sphere gas
as computed by this lawrence livermore
computer
as part of this tradition of thinking
about hot sphere gases
okay so
um
uh my intersection was this was that
1972 when i was 12 years old long time
ago
um i uh
was like trying to learn physics and so
i got this whole collection of college
physics textbooks including this
berkeley uh um series of physics books
um volume five of which had this lovely
sort of film strip picture of um of the
behavior of these of these uh hard
spheres supposedly
in um
in in something like an idealized gas
so i was really interested in that
picture
and
i
was really interested in the phenomenon
of the second or thermodynamics
of the sort of tendency of things to get
more random and so on and of this fact
that you could take these all these
molecules and you could make a
collective statement about what they
would do that would correspond to the
second order of thermodynamics even
without knowing a lot of details about
these molecules
okay so in fact one of my first serious
sort of physics-oriented computer
programs was in 1973 on a very primitive
kind of computer where i um uh i tried
to make a simulator of those kinds of
particles bouncing around the box
in the in the
convention of naming programs at the
time because you had to they were on
paper tapes and things and you would
write the name of the program on the
tape and and maybe you'd index them
somehow i called that one s part for
steven's particle thing because people
usually use their first initial and some
shortening of the name of the um
uh the thing so my my spark program um
was was one of my early efforts in
simulating things as it turned out it
was a pretty crummy simulation because
in order to compute things about hard
sphere gases you really need floating
point numbers you really need sort of
precise information on what the
positions of the spheres are um and i
was not able really to have that on this
very small and primitive computer that i
was dealing with so i sort of
approximated things by just putting all
the particles on a grid and i imagine
that instead of hard spheres they would
just be hard squares
and i imagine some sort of collision
rules for these hard squares and i
programmed these things
well
interestingly
i programmed this i thought i was going
to see second order thermodynamics
behavior but i didn't
and
many years later i came to realize that
there were detailed conservation laws
in this thing with a grid of particles
on a on on particles on the square grid
there were detailed conservation laws
that prevented the kind of
thermalization the kind of tendency to
more towards randomness that you would
usually get and even if you put weird
shaped obstructions
in there you could still get randomness
but i didn't know that when i was 13
years old or whatever and i was writing
this this code and so that for a long
time made me think i really don't
understand how the second order of
thermodynamics works
well
by
the mid-1980s i sort of redid this this
uh experiment with idealized particles
but now on a hexagonal grid or on other
kinds of grids and observed all kinds of
randomization and then a few years after
that i realized that this idea of
computational irreducibility really
explains why the second order
thermodynamics works how all these uh
phenomena of being able to go from sort
of the the very orderly pattern of
things bouncing around to disorderly
patterns of things bouncing around how
that works
and how it really doesn't depend on
things like the sense of dependence on
initial conditions and the fact that
spheres bounce further away when they
are hitting off center and all those
kinds of things it really didn't affect
wasn't affected by any of those things
but when i came to write when i was
writing my book new kind of science i
wanted to fill in the history of lots of
things including the history of that
book cover that had sort of led me on
this path towards statistical mechanics
and so on
and uh and had talked about hot sphere
gases and so i contacted bernie alder
and said where did those pictures come
from and he said well actually they were
kind of a cheat
they were not in fact based on a true
simulation of things bouncing around we
couldn't trace them for very long on
that kind of computer instead there were
random numbers introduced actually using
von neumann's middle square random
number method
and really the randomness that you see
in the pictures is because of a random
number being introduced into into
velocities of things not because of
accurately tracing the um the collisions
of these particles so that was a kind of
a downer but i only learned that after i
already thought i'd really understood
the second order thermodynamics and no
longer really cared about those details
um but it was sort of an interesting
thing that um that book cover was
actually a fake in the end
um in a sense
i will say that back in those days one
of the things that was discovered in the
1960s
um in simulations of hot sphere gases is
this phenomenon of so-called long-time
tails
you might think when you have all these
molecules bouncing around that any
correlation between molecules any any
any sort of collective any any uh that
that would quickly be kind of ground
down it would quickly randomize things
would quickly randomize even on a
microscopic scale but it turned out that
there was this kind of power law
distribution you might think it would
sort of exponentially randomize but
actually there's a power or tail that
was observed and that's associated with
with large-scale kind of hydrodynamic
effects that are sort of you're starting
to see the emergence of even in these
molecular systems
but so anyway that that's a a bit of a
history of hot sphere gases they're a
little bit of a squiggly business
because
uh you know this sensitive dependence on
initial conditions this detail about
sort of exactly how
whether the spheres hit on center or not
um those things cause one to lose
numerical precision quite rapidly and so
when it's not getting an accurate
trajectory for every molecule um after
not very long if one's using fixed
you know floating point arithmetic with
a fixed precision and so on and in fact
one would have to use sort of uh you
know linearly increasing precision or
exponentially increasing accuracy so to
speak effect exponentially increasing
sort of uh fineness of scales um in
order to trace completely accurately
what happens in the heart sphere gas and
that quickly becomes impractical
so so it's a little difficult to really
know for sure what happens in a hot
sphere of gas there are most likely a
phenomenon it's usually called shadowing
which basically says that the thing you
get even by making those approximations
will be in some sense close to the thing
that you would get if you were to do it
precisely
but um uh you know i think that hot
sphere gases and things like them have
perhaps not received as much attention
as they might because of some of these
difficult footnotes i would say that
there are these cellular automaton
systems like the cellular automaton
fluid system that i made up in the in
the mid 1980s
that
kind of avoid all those issues by having
really discrete elements and being able
to have sort of discrete collisions that
one can treat precisely
so anyway a little bit on the history of
hot sphere gases
uh
oh my the um
well
greel asks a somewhat related question
how did the study of non-air dynamics
come about
i would imagine it would be a known
thing after newton's work
well no it wasn't
the what happened is
newton formulated his laws of mechanics
uh sort of was able to
uh sort of compute with them using
calculus
and so on but what people were
interested in were the laws of mechanics
not
so much
uh sort of your arbitrary equation
they wanted the the particular equation
okay so a couple of different branches
happened
um
newton was interested in the particular
laws of mechanics
uh people like euler
in the 1700s started looking more
generally at sort of the the structure
of certain kinds of differential
equations particularly linear
differential equations and so on well
they it was difficult enough to deal
with linear differential equations all
kinds of exotic mathematical functions
got invented bessel functions
hypogeometric functions all these kinds
of things was difficult enough to deal
with those kinds of equations let alone
dealing with sort of all kinds of
elaborate nonlinearities in these
equations
um i would say that um
well let's see the the um
uh there's certain very sort of specific
nonlinearities that could get introduced
that lead to these kinds of special
functions but sort of just throw in an
arbitrary non-linearity wasn't really a
thing about which one could say very
much with these equations people were
concerned about you know how many
regular singular points are there in
this differential equation all this kind
of thing that only works for pretty
specific forms of differential equations
so differential equations abstractly
studied by people like euler
and
but
not really the true nonlinear case then
uh people started studying other kinds
of
of physical systems like fluid mechanics
the navier-stokes equations for fluid
flow which our linear equations were
developed but people were really mostly
keen on solving them using mathematical
functions and they could only do that in
cases which were rather special like
flow past a sphere and at low reynolds
numbers where the flow is moving very
smoothly and
where there were
sort of special cases where it was
possible to get
exact analytical solutions but by the
way worth realizing that we forget
sometimes
the the modernity of modernity so to
speak with respect to these kinds of
things
back in the time of newton the way you
solved an equation was by writing down a
mathematical formula for the solution
this idea that you might have
a a numerical approximation that you
dealt with just wasn't there
the the thing that was sort of the
intermediate case was the idea of series
solutions expanding the things as a
series and that was known
uh by i think newton had had that idea
certainly maclaurin by by 1720s had the
idea of expanding a function in a series
and approximating it as sort of an
algebraic approximation but the idea
that we would routinely have today of
let's just solve that equation
numerically that idea really wasn't
around at that time
so then
when it comes to kind of nonlinear
effects
um
the the kind of the big problem of the
eighteen hundreds in terms of
mathematical physics was the three body
problem the gravitational three body
problem the motion of the earth moon and
sun or idealized versions of that under
mutual gravity was a super hard problem
to solve
newton had tried to work on it he hadn't
gotten the right answer
people really needed to know it
accurately if he wanted to predict when
eclipses would happen things like this
was very very hard to solve and people
mostly thought about solving it either
let's him find a mathematical function
that somehow cracks it or eventually
let's find a series expansion that will
uh will be a convergence series where we
by taking just a few terms we get a good
approximation to the answer that's what
people tried to do
um people poincare around 1900 very much
got into that business
and
made some more general observations
about the ways that
uh dynamical systems systems where of
dynamics where things are moving around
how that would work
and he started looking at um
uh things like um
the divergence of trajectories
in um as a result of things being in
spaces of negative curvature the
divergence of trajectories for example
in the case of these balls bouncing off
each other things like this
um
and that led to sort of early ideas of
what were later called they happen of
exponents
uh leap and i think have been studying
these things in the context of of um
uh more like control systems and so on i
think
um rather than uh
sort of these more abstract more
mechanical more pure mechanical
dynamical systems but so poincare is
sort of an early example of dynamical
systems
um then
people got interested in
uh
people tried to characterize the
behavior of dynamical systems uh
poincare had invented topology as a way
to characterize some sort of structures
of solutions later on the method of
symbolic dynamics this is 1930s or so
was invented where you just sort of said
we don't care about the exact value of
where things were we're just going to
bend things in sort of and say it's in
the a position b position c position
and thinking about sort of the discrete
mathematics
of how those different sort of uh the
sequences of symbols that would
correspond to particular um uh to
particular behaviors
okay so then we get to the 1950s
probably
and well actually i'm going to let me
let me back up a second 1930s another
important thing
the vanderpull oscillator
and van der paul equation and so on
so
back in uh
let's see amplifiers for radio have been
invented
in the very late let's see i think they
were first really used by
um in the 1920s and so on with vacuum
tubes and things like this
um and people uh so you were trying to
amplify a radio signal
and
there was an equation that represented
the amplification of the progressive
amplification of a radio signal that
equation was a nasty non-linear
differential equation
and it had
all kinds of weird characteristics it
had all kinds of things where sometimes
you would get
a limit cycle a kind of a a single
frequency sometimes you'd get multiple
frequencies it would be a will be a mess
this was something that people started
analyzing well in 1930s i think
um looking at the behavior of those
equations and realizing it's big mess we
don't really know what's going on
okay so then that was those were
differential equations
in the 1950s
people started looking at what would now
be called logistic maps
and there have been some precursors i
think to this but
in areas like ecology and so on people
were saying well this number of fish
this year
if they're this number this year how
many will there be next year and you've
got these kind of recurrence relations
that said given the number of fish this
year how many fish will you have next
year and that led to the idea of an
iterated map where you have some some
value at a particular year and then a
value at the next year and the next year
and so on now this idea of iterations
like that
that had been invented for integers
back well fibonacci had talked about
that in the fibonacci series in around
12
1200 a.d
and uh those things were were widely
discussed difference equations were
widely discussed along with differential
equations i mean george boole for
example famously wrote two little books
one about differential equations one
about difference equations
um actually when we were putting
difference equations recurrence
equations into wolfram language
oh and 15 20 years ago now
it's sort of notable that we were still
using bool's book on difference
equations that hadn't been superseded
whereas bull's book on differential
equations have been vastly superseded by
lots of other work on differential
equations anyway so this idea of
iterated maps
of real numbers didn't really i think
emerge until uh pretty much seriously
until the 1950s
and by the
1950s there started to be some computer
experiments on it and people started
noticing oh there are all kinds of
interesting effects and so on
those were things that showed up now
another big thing in nonlinear dynamics
was lorentz equations 1962 at lorenz
in sort of a simplification of the
equations of meteorology
um a modal truncation just looking at
kind of just thinking about things as
the first sort of three sine wave levels
or something of motion of
of air in the atmosphere derived this um
set of equations which were the lorentz
equations um which have this feature
that they have sensor dependence on
initial conditions they show complicated
behavior by the way those two things are
not necessarily related people kind of
got very very confused about the fact
that the reason there's complexity in
the solution to the equations is because
there is sensor dependence on initial
conditions that's not really right
you can have sensitive depends on
initial conditions and have very simple
behavior um you need some kind of
dependence on initial conditions to get
complicated behavior but the complicated
behavior can arise even when you don't
have precise real numbers where you can
discuss meaningfully that kind of sense
of dependence on initial connections
that was sort of the discovery of mine
in the 1980s with cellular automata and
things like that that you could get sort
of complex behavior even without uh
having sort of real numbers and having
this idea of we're excavating digits in
the initial conditions which is sort of
the the one of the mathematically
analyzable parts of things like lorentz
equations
so in any case the the um the sort of
the notion of dynamical systems theory
kind of started to emerge the the one of
the big results so ideas was that
usually you have one of these
differential equations you keep it
running for a long time it'll either go
to a fixed point it'll just uh
everything will just go to a fixed value
or maybe it'll make a limit cycle where
you are continually sort of circling
around a series of values and that's
what happens for example the predator
prey equations the lack of altera
equations which i think what came from
the 1940s if i'm not mistaken um
those to have those kinds of behavior
but there's another kind of behavior
that shows up in some of these equations
which is what got called by the 1960s i
guess a strange attractor a an attractor
something that all the solutions of the
equation kind of led to but it's a
strange attractor in the sense that it's
not
a fixed point where you're just going to
one point or a limit cycle you're just
cycling around it's something where
something much more complicated happens
and something like the lorenz attractor
shows a strange attractor it's lorenzo
equations produces a strange attractor
sort of the vanderbal equation uh
although it wasn't analyzed until later
but
these kinds of things the the occurrence
of these kinds of strange attractors and
their analysis that really got started
seriously in the 1960s
when people could do numerical
simulations they could actually solve
the equations make pictures of these
things and so on
um and then i would say dynamical
systems theory um kind of uh this this
notion of symbolic dynamics that have
been introduced in the 1930s um that
sort of became much more sophisticated
for analyzing dynamical systems in the
1950s and 1960s 1970s
then
the other thing that happened was this
notion of complex dynamics
of being able to do things where you're
iterating a complex function where you
say z goes to z squared plus a constant
for example the analysis of that had
been started by people like julia and
fatu back in around 1900 but it hadn't
really gone very far at that time and
that that whole thing sort of got re
re-you know reinvigorated by looking at
iterative maps and particularly mitchell
feigenbaum's discovery in
1976 i think
that um
uh
uh of universality and the period
doubling in its relative maps that kind
of gave one a sort of quantitative way
in to these very non-linear systems
these systems where it had not really
been possible to use sort of standard
formula based approaches it gave one
kind of a a way into that and so that
increased the popularity quite a bit um
uh with um um
uh with these things
so
um
in uh
um uh let's see so so the
uh and that led so complex dynamics
which is really iterating complex
functions
complex not in the sense of complicated
but in the sense of involving complex
numbers and amount and square roots of
minus one things like that
that has a very beautiful theory a lot
of that is very very sort of a theory
you can really work out a lot with and
that really sort of i would say came
into its own probably 1980s and beyond
and so that's led to sort of the current
interest in dynamical systems theory
non-linear dynamics
i would say that there are different
branches off of nanodynamics some of the
work on differential equations in the
1940s and 1950s
led to the study of control systems
what happens there is a little confusing
because the equations might start
incredibly non-linear they're very
non-linear things that are doing very
complicated stuff but when you have a
system in con that is under is
controlled you're typically controlling
it to be precisely tuning its parameters
exactly so it doesn't go off into all
this wild non-linear behavior so whereas
the system which you study in control
theory might be a system with all kinds
of complicated uh non-linearities you
mostly don't see that because when it's
in control
it is showing only this sort of linear
variation around this point where it is
controlled so to speak and that's part
of what happened in in fields like
cybernetics which had some sort of
intersection with nonlinear dynamics
early on
but um because of cybernetics it was
sort of about control of things in in in
animals and machines and so on and sort
of the first assumption would be well
we've got these differential equations
let's see what their solutions are but
then it kind of turned into just that
point at which there is control where
there really isn't the same kind of
non-linearity that you see in general
and that same on that non-linearity is
what leads to all that complicated
behavior so you don't really see that
when you're studying control theory
even though some of the equations are
the exact same equations
so that's sort of a separate branch off
of non-aerodynamics which isn't really
that nonlinear because at the controlled
point it has it is sort of linearized
well let's see
there's a long description of that
um
uh let's see
um
all right
um
well there's a question here
from blue asking how important are
complex numbers in the history of
science and technology would the current
state be possible without them
you know complex numbers were really
introduced by cardano around 1 500
uh as
necessary technology in solving cubic
equations equations of the form x cubed
you know x to the 3 plus
sum x squared plus whatever um
solving equations of that form
actually forced both negative numbers
and complex numbers to be taken
seriously
and they sort of came in a bundle
strangely enough because negative
numbers seem much easier to understand
but people haven't really seen the need
for
an entity of a negative number it's like
well you owe money or your owed money
those are kind of things you can
describe in words why have a
mathematical notation that represents a
negative balance or some such other
thing um it doesn't it's sort of
unnecessary it didn't need to be
mathematicized it kind of reminds one of
modern times where
we i've been on this quest for the last
940-something years of sort of making
the world computable finding ways to
represent computationally all kinds of
things in the world and you might say
why bother why do we want to represent
kind of things which we would otherwise
describe in words computationally well
one good reason right now is because
then computers can help us figure out
what's going on with them but there are
other reasons of sort of having a
certain clarity and streamline form of
presentation you could have asked the
same questions back in 1500 where people
were debating were negative numbers
worth having um why don't we just
describe it in words but it turns out
negative numbers are pretty useful that
it's pretty it really is a major
streamlining of the way that one does
mathematics to have this idea that you
can take you know when you say uh seven
minus five that you can pick out the
minus five as a thing all to itself
and uh say seven plus minus five
in a sense
that ability to take out this lump that
is the negative five thing
as opposed to just having to say words
about uh about how it's subtracting five
and so on the ability to sort of take
this this lump that represents something
about itself it's a very computational
kind of idea it's a very symbolic kind
of idea it's the kind of idea that for
example in our wolfram language uh kind
of computational language development
this notion of making things into sort
of objects not really in the
object-oriented programming sense but
into kind of symbolic objects symbolic
expressions that you can kind of pick up
and do things with that's the super
powerful idea and we're sort of seeing
that idea work out in the computational
context all over the place
but old cardano had kind of had that
idea for negative numbers and for
complex numbers
now
once one had the idea of complex numbers
it's really a convenient packaging
of
uh sort of a pair of numbers you could
equally well say well where is that in
the plane there is some position it's
you know
uh coordinates three 4 in the plane but
you can also sort of package that into
the single number 3 plus 4i
and that packaging just turns out to be
very convenient mathematically there are
a lot of interesting properties where
there are direct analogs of things that
are true about integers and real numbers
and so on that are also true
about the gaussian integers the complex
generalization of the integers and
complex numbers
so a lot of facts
that are true about about ordinary real
numbers are also true about complex
numbers and so that again allows one to
take a lot of machinery that was
developed for real numbers and apply it
directly to complex numbers rather than
having to chase around saying oh it's
pairs of numbers and we do this thing to
these pairs of numbers which would be an
equivalent way to do it you could have
pairs of real numbers the real and
imaginary parts of our complex numbers
and you could trace those all around but
much more convenient to have this kind
of mathematical packaging into a complex
number
now you know will
you know could could modern technology
have been invented without complex
numbers oh sure
uh they're just a convenient packaging
you know back in the
1830s i think
uh william rowe and hamilton generalized
the complex numbers to the so-called
quaternions instead of having just one
and i
as the units you have one i j and k as
the units
people thought at the time that maybe
quaternions were like the you know
amazing and they were going to solve
science basically they didn't
quaternions are convenient sometimes
they allow one to represent for example
rotations in three-dimensional space
they have other nice mathematical
properties but they were not kind of um
killer additions to the arsenal of
things that one had to do
to to sort of do science with
so that's a case where sort of the
quaternions were a little bit like you
would say the complex numbers well they
were great but the quaternions would be
even better but they weren't you can go
on even from the quaternions the
octonians
certainly people are enthusia there are
octonion enthusiasts
but they're not they haven't yet proven
themselves to be sort of front and
center things that are important in
science they might relate to some of the
symmetry groups
for that show up in particle physics and
things like that um that remains to be
really established and for example and
things like our model of physics
by the way in case you're wondering uh
you go from
uh you know the real numbers the complex
numbers the quaternions the octonions
and that's kind of the end
of of numbers that have sort of
number-like behavior of generalizations
of numbers with number-like behavior you
know for example when you go to
quaternions you lose commutativity you
lose the fact that x times y is equal to
y times x for all numbers x and y and
when you go to octonions you lose
associativity the fact that
um x times
per n y times z is the same as x times y
times z
and when you go beyond that you lose
other properties that you think any
self-respecting numbers should have so
you can't really go much further well
you can go further but but um uh
uh
kali numbers right uh the other
generalization i think hyper-complex
numbers
um
but uh they're not as popular but so you
know so i don't think you know certainly
uh complex numbers are a very convenient
packaging they allow one to not have to
talk about sines and cosines but to talk
about each of the i thetas they allow
one to do fourier analysis in a nice
clean way
they allow one to represent things more
cleanly i don't think they are strictly
necessary i mean let me give an example
the idea of vectors
is is again a packaging idea you could
and when maxwell wrote out his maxwell's
equations originally he had the x
component of the electric field the y
component of the electric field the z
component of the electric field but it's
more convenient to package those all
into a vector and say it's the electric
field vector that has three components
because you can do things with that
vector you can take the divergence of
the vector as a vector you can take the
um uh you can uh you can add vectors
together as a vector this is what for
example in wolfen language uh leads to
our notion of listability where you can
have lists of things they don't have to
be numbers or even lists of lists of
lists of things if you want to but that
whole sort of list thing gets treated as
a a single object and you can add them
together you can add constants to them
things like this
that idea the idea of packaging things
in vectors is another very powerful idea
so complex numbers are a packaging idea
you could always write out all the
components but it's a convenient
packaging and that's certainly
streamlined things that have gotten done
other things that have been figured out
merely because complex numbers exist yes
definitely in fields of mathematics um
there are definitely places where sort
of the thinking in terms of complex
numbers is important you know this is
why for example computational language
and thinking in terms of sort of the
computational packaging of things is
important to let you think about things
in different ways
and sort of complex numbers are a very
very very junior example of that from
back in the 1500s
i think i need to
wrap up uh
soon
um
maybe one more
well let's have two simple two questions
one easy one not so easy aaron asks have
you ever seen cellular automaton like
objects produced by jacquard loom so the
jacquard loom was a a very good early
example of automation
from 1800 it was a thing a weaving loom
that was some
uh weaving fabric
and people wanted to weave patterns in
the fabric and jacquard
um
invented this idea of using punch cards
where the punch cards would determine
where the where the needles would kind
of weave next
and so
from 1800 this idea of punch cards
started up and that allowed one to have
these very elaborate patterns that could
be sort of produced on um
in in weaving so to speak
so that was that was kind of the idea
now needless to say
you could uh if by the time you have a
computer in the loop you don't actually
need the punch card you just have a
computer directly generating the
instructions to move the needles how you
want to move them and so
with cellular automata you've
essentially got this array of values
and you have a very simple rule that
determines the new value based on the
old values and you could use that to
essentially make an infinite loom where
you are computing the positions of the
needles from their previous positions so
to speak and yes people have done that
and um
uh there are a number of lovely things
like scarves for example that people
have have woven that way
um
and
i have to say i i did
consider at one point um
the um
making
a collection of sort of designer scarves
that were cellular automaton based that
was sort of an infinite scarf where but
with a cellular automaton pattern one
can have something which is a never
repeating scarf so everybody gets a
unique scarf coming off this sort of
infinite loom so to speak and i did um
explore this a bit
um and uh i learned more than i would
like to know about kind of the um
um
you know alpaca goats and what kind of
um thread you have to have to have nice
some
uh nice kind of um uh good feeling and
and um and and uh high quality scarves
and so on and the different weird things
that happen of different parts to the
animal and the different colors of their
of their and
of their
of their fur and so on and um uh you
know what effect that has when you dye
the thing and you start weaving the
thing and you you et cetera et cetera et
cetera i got i got quite deep into it
the end result of it was it's too
complicated for us to make scarves but
other people have made them and i think
often with knitting um
and uh
yeah i'm i'm now i'm i'm exhausting my
knowledge of of the processes of of uh
knitting versus crocheting versus
uh uh other kinds of things um but um
uh but but yes there have been such
things made and i think you can probably
even find them on um
on uh you know the etsy's of this world
and so on
um but it is to me it's very remarkable
that the jakarta loom was such an early
invention in the history of a history of
automation
all right i'm going to
try and tackle one more thing it's a
question from
um something like that
curious about my thoughts on the
technological singularity
you know
okay so
somebody recently told me that
this had a different origin than i
thought but the idea that sort of the
pace of innovation the pace of
this invention
is
so ever increasing that at some point
it will basically become infinite
is
a belief that's been around at different
times
for a while i mean it's sort of ironic
that back 100 years ago but no in 1900
people were making statements like
everything that has been invented or is
worth inventing has already been
invented
um everything that's worth inventing has
already been invented so they said right
before just a whole bunch of new
inventions and and things got made
well
sort of the flip side of that i think
1940s 1950s
um i'm not sure if this is to be
attributed to stanislaw lem
or to jack good
or to
other people
but um i know that
um there sort of was the concept um
uh maybe von neumann talked about this
i'm not sure
um this concept
that uh there could be
a sort of a rapidly accelerating pace of
innovation
together with the idea that eventually
machines would make machines and then
the pace of innovation would get even
faster and it would lead eventually to
this this moment where there's a
singularity where sort of things things
take off at an infinite speed
now you know people observe these
different things like for example people
observe that the scientific literature
is exponentially increasing in size
that's one kind of observation things
are discoveries are happening more
quickly some people would interpret that
to me
other people say
you know
innovation has ended there are no
interesting new innovations it's all
just uh
different social media platforms or
something here are from here on out
um i think that both of these things are
kind of false observations
i think what happens i think i've said
this many times sort of the pace that
the rhythm of innovation tends to be
new method is invented
new direction has gone in
five to ten years low hanging fruit to
be picked
very rapid innovation in some area that
you may never have heard of before may
not even had a name before
and then sort of the low-hanging fruit
is picked things level off there might
be 50 or 100 years of progressive uh
sort of incremental innovation but not
that same rapid innovation and so when
you look at fields that are in that kind
of cruise phase those are the ones you
most know about and they look like
they're in cruise phase and they look
like there's not a lot of sort of true
innovation going on
now doesn't mean that when there's when
they're in cruise phase that there isn't
a lot more work going on in those areas
and certainly academic papers are a sign
of certain kinds of academic work and
there are many other forces that lead to
rapid increase in the numbers of papers
in all these
fields as they get established and
institutionalized and so on that have
nothing to do with this sort of true
here's a really new direction kind of
thing and mostly in fact the the sort of
force of all of that sort of
institutional structure tends to slow
down the rate of of sort of true often
often the sort of weird direction
innovation
so but this question of of whether
uh for example that the production of
kind of um
you know ais will make new ais and
eventually the ais will sort of become
infinitely
uh rapidly
um uh innovating relative to us
well okay so this is a slightly
complicated issue but i think that
the the main thing to understand is
um
it's not like you measure iq points for
an ai and you just go oh first it was
100 then it was first it was like 40 and
then it was 100 and then it was 200 300
700. etc it just doesn't work that way
that's not whether sort of such things
measure anything meaningful is is
debatable but the whole point is
that
what we learn from things like my
principle of computational equivalence
is that once you reach a certain level
which isn't very hard to reach
things everything is capable of
universal computation everything can do
any computation you ask for maybe it can
do it slightly faster maybe it can do it
in a slightly different way
but it doesn't do completely different
kinds of computations so in a sense
there's no ability to reach
it's it's some
there's both
there's a there's not a um
uh it's not the case that you kind of
suddenly get into this area where you're
sort of infinitely able to do
computations
um i think that um uh well let's see how
to think about this
i mean the um
there will certainly be singularities
in the future of
of history so to speak i mean one very
obvious one is uh you know effective
human immortality you know right now
we measure time in part in generations
and in human lifespans
and
when and i say when not if those become
effectively infinite
uh
that will really change the way in which
you know one thinks about time and the
way in which one thinks about sort of
the the rate at which things happen
i think that um you know this question
of whether there will come a point
where sort of there's infinite rate of
innovation
relative to what we humans do well
here's the thing
there's
in the
that it is very easy to get very rapid
innovation the only problem is we don't
recognize what it is so you know when
you look out at little programs out in
the computational universal possible
programs it's very easy to go and grab a
program which just really interesting
things well
it does really complicated things but
what is it doing and why do we care we
don't know
you know in our modern view of the
rouliad the the kind of entangled limit
of all possible computations
what we're doing
by uh kind of going out
in um and just going sort of sampling
that program out there it's like we're
we're jumping through rulial space to
some other places in the woolly ad we
live in this particular local region of
rural space where we kind of have a
certain way of understanding what's
going on but we can jump to other parts
of real space
where all sorts of
complicated things are going on but
they're just not related to the things
that we understand from our experience
in our region of rural space
and so i think the thing to realize is
that in a sense the ultimate
technological singularity is probably
the ruliad the ruliad contains all of
these possible computations and so on
the problem is while the ruliad is
everywhere it's right there it's it's
what we live in so to speak
our sampling of it is much more limited
so in a sense the um the thing that we
might be asking is uh how much you know
to to reach a quotes technological
singularity what that's effectively
saying is that we are we are able to
ingest we're able to make technological
a sort of infinite expanse of the ruliad
one thing i might mention
um is what is technology i mean
technology is you take things from the
natural world or maybe the computational
world and you apply them for human
purposes you discover how to take iron
and turn it into
useful pieces of steel and so on you
discover how to take um uh you know i
mentioned um
uh radio and make it something you know
electromagnetic waves make them
something useful and so on we're taking
these things that sort of in some sense
exist out in the world and we're finding
a way to make a bridge to make them
useful to us as humans and that's the
story of technology
and i actually wrote about this recently
i wrote a little piece about some
uh uh alien intelligence and the concept
of technology i should have mentioned
but i didn't think of it um this uh the
relationship with technological
singularity because i think the right
way to think about this is
uh it is trivial
it is right there in the rouliad is all
of this possible structure but the issue
is have we grabbed it as technology and
to say there's infinite technology is to
imply that we are capable of
understanding sort of this infinite set
of purposes to which that technology
might be put and we're just not
the way that human sort of understanding
and purpose evolves is quite slow and
where you know gradually we get a new
paradigm for thinking about things
gradually this happens gradually that
happens there's a kind of thread of
understanding that we follow that we
followed throughout the course of kind
of the development of civilization that
allows us to kind of step slowly uh
further and further out in the rouliad
but to say well there is a lot of
roulette out there but we could in
principle go grab well yes we could it's
just not for us humans to do now we
might also say well how about we get the
ais to do that forget the humans let's
get the ais to do that great it's easier
for an aids to do that it's easy for us
to do kind of ruliology and jump out and
go find you know there's pieces of rural
space that we can do things with the
problem is they don't connect to what
you humans care about and so we might
call it you know it might be that we're
sampling lots of the ruliad but it isn't
technology
in the sense that we humans mean when we
say technology because technology
presumably is something useful to us
we can see all kinds of elaborate
computations going on but the ais can do
all kinds of elaborate computations it's
easy to get an ai to do elaborate
computations the issue is are there
computations that we care about or
understand
or or sometimes we can understand the
results in a machine learning system we
might know the result is it identifies
the images even if we can't trace
through how did it identify the image
but if what it's doing is so kind of
free range that it's just sort of
producing complicated patterns like a
cellular automaton like a a woven
cellular automaton scarf or something
going off to infinity with its
complicated patterns it's just producing
these complicated patterns and we don't
have a way to to sort of merge those
with human purposes
i might say that kind of my life work of
building our computational language well
from language is a story of trying to
merge the computational
with sort of what is human
understandable and human purposes
because the whole point of a
computational language is to define a
way of specifying things computationally
that is specifying things people care
about in ways that people understand
having a language that people can can
write and read um that represents things
computationally that provides kind of a
bridge to this great power that exists
in in doing kind of uh in in the
computational universe that full power
is this kind of bubbling ocean of of of
stuff that we don't have ways to use
right now
i i will say i i know i should should uh
i have to leave in a moment here but um
as as looking at our
summer school and summer camp where
sort of the technology stack is over
from language um i have to say
particularly for the high school kids
who are coming in middle school kids um
i i do feel like
if you give people computational
language you're giving them a superpower
it's kind of remarkable that these
things that you know appear they sort of
appear magic to lots of other people
that you know you can take this question
and you can just
do things with it in ways that people
just couldn't understand that sort of
seem like magic but actually it's just
the application of computational
language and the assistance of your
computer that allows you to do things
and it's sort of a a an interesting
experience of seeing kind of uh you know
it's one of these things where there are
different skills people can learn but
this is a very strong superpower kind of
skill that lets people effectively do
magical things so to speak uh just with
computational language
anyway
the um
uh i should probably wrap up here but
i'm glad to be back doing these live
streams these are fun for me i hope
people find them interesting um
uh with respect to the thing i was just
discussing i i do recommend this piece
that i wrote a few weeks ago about um
uh alien intelligence and the concept of
technology i think it's it's very
related to this
um
so uh thanks very much and see you
another time
bye for now